with the season pass the experience of
watchdogs to becomes even bigger more
immersive and definitely more dangerous
in our first DLC the t-phone content
bundle embraced the style of t-bone with
this custom car flipping truck and a new
outfit and take on smarter and more
lethal enemies co-op missions become
more challenging with an all-new
difficulty level in the massive human
conditions DLC you join forces with
Lenny and Jordi in three new hour-long
story missions in the first mission
automata dead sec unveils the dark
secrets of a biometric car company
Marcus teams up with Jordi in bad
medicine to take on the Russian mafia
encaustic progress Marcus burst with
biohacker Lenny to expose a company
that's been experimenting on the
homeless on top of all this players will
have to adapt to the new elite level
co-op play and enhanced enemies fight
for your life in a brand new co-op mode
as hackers from dead sec and primate go
head-to-head in our third DLC no
compromise
explore san Francisco's seedy underbelly
in an all new story mission the season
pass also gives you immediate access to
the psychedelic pack and the root access
bundle to make sure you arrive in San
Francisco with fresh outfits vehicles
weapons and more in watch dogs two
players will experience a massive open
world the season pass expands that
experience even further with tons of new
missions features and challenges San
Francisco just got a lot bigger what
happens next is up to you play mission
packs first on PlayStation
spin us on